okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the nervous system the nervous
system is what allows us to interact
with the outside world it allows us to
experience sensations and it allows us
to react as well so let's have a look at
the central nervous system so the
central nervous system is where
everything within the nervous system is
coordinated from we often see central
nervous system abbreviated to just CNS
central nervous system it consists of
the brain which contains millions of
millions of neurons and the spinal cord
the spinal cord is loads of neurons like
bundles of neurons which run down from
the brain and then can run out to
different parts of the body now what
we're going to see is how the nervous
system allows us to react to different
situations I apologize in advance for my
terrible drawing but let's imagine I've
got this here which is showing a bus
which is about to to drive off and I'm
gonna miss my bus so I need to
experience this I need to be able to see
this register it and do something about
it and the nervous system allows me to
do that so first of all the bus is
referred to as a stimulus because this
is the thing that I'm going to react to
eventually so you always start off for
the stimulus something in the external
environment that I'm going to experience
so in order to ever be able to detect a
stimulus I need some kind of receptor to
receive the signal so in this particular
case my receptors are in my eyes now and
we'll all receptors are linked to being
able to sense things so we find
receptors in our eyes in our skin in our
nose in our ears and our tongue because
all of these allow us to see touch smell
hear and taste so in this particular
example because my stimulus is a visual
stimulus my receptors are in my in my
eyes are as
so so receptors what receive the signal
right now after I've received the signal
I need to send that information to the
central nervous system the CNS in order
to coordinate from some kind of response
now this doesn't just jump from the
receptor to the CNS it needs to travel
down a neuron so those electrical
impulses travel down neurons called
sensory neurons now it's easy to
remember that they're called sensory
neurons because they're involved in
sensation the sensation of seeing this
stimulus okay so it's traveled down
Center on to the CNS so how I'm going to
want to react eventually is I'm going to
want to run towards the bus so I can try
and get the bus before it drives off so
in order to do that I need muscles in my
legs to be able to work or a signal to
go to my legs to tell them to run so now
I'm not going to in the moment obviously
this is just a floating brain and
sputters spinal cord and this stops just
about where your tailbone is so let's
just imagine this person's leg it's just
here and the muscle in the leg is right
there so what I'm needing to do is I'm
needing to send a signal from the
central nervous system from the brain
all the way down the spinal cord to the
muscle in the leg so there's the muscle
in the leg so I can tell so I can run
towards the bus now the type of neuron
that allows us to kind of is connect to
the muscle and allows us to move it's
called a motor neuron so this
information travels from the central
nervous system as an electrical impulse
down a motor neuron to the muscle in my
leg so the muscle is called an effector
because this is where I have my actual
effect it's off the muscle but it could
also be a gland and the way I remember
motor neuron and muscle is Emmis for
motor neuron Ms for muscle Ms for
movement so motor neurons and
only attached muscles that allow us to
move so the effector in this case is the
muscle in my leg and therefore I'm going
to be able to move towards this bus to
catch it so finally I have a response so
my response is just the physical action
as a result of the action of the
effector so what actually gonna happen
what's gonna happen is I'm going to run
towards the van so my response is that
contraction of the muscle in order to
run towards the van obviously there'll
be more muscles at work here not just
one in one of my legs they're gonna be
muscles all over my body but it will
work in a similar way so just a quick
recap the stimulus is something that we
could detect within the environment the
receptor is involved with sensation and
allows us to receive that signal the
information travels down a sensory
neuron to the central nervous system
because the central nervous system needs
to coordinate response we then send the
signal down a motor neuron which is
going to eventually allowed us to move
an effector is usually a muscle but it
could also be a gland and once it motor
neuron sends a signal to the effector we
could have a response which is suitable
for what we try to achieve and in this
case which want to run to catch this bus
thank you very much